live at 11 live local now
thank you for joining us on 8 news now
at 11 i'm bryan loftis when the clock
strikes midnight
clark county will officially be back to
running at 100 percent
all capacity restrictions will simply go
away ushering in a new milestone for the
valley as we move forward through the
cobit pandemic
madison kimbrough has more on what the
mood is like around the valley
brian it's a time we've all been waiting
for and with the full reopening
happening in less than an hour
people in vegas are living it up as you
can see right here on the strip
and then also in downtown on fremont
street there will be a lot of
celebrating going on tonight that is for
sure
happening downtown fremont street
experience will be hosting what they are
calling downtown
rocks again three music stages will be
set up where people of all ages
can come on down and enjoy live music
from a variety of bands
that will be playing until 4 a.m and the
viva vision canopy screens will be
running a countdown clock counting down
to midnight here on the strip we spoke
to several visitors and locals
who are ready to start the month off of
june restriction free
it's great it's an american summer
following the pandemic everybody
deserves to get out i guess with how
packed it is normally i don't think it's
going to be much of a difference here
and with this full reopen which is
easily one of the biggest to happen thus
far
in the country restaurants and stores
will most likely go back to regular
business hours
and there will be no capacity
restrictions however that doesn't mean
that we are done with social distancing
and mask wearing as each business is
allowed to implement
what they feel comfortable with within
their own business
reporting from the las vegas strip
madison kimbrough 8 news now
all right mattis